- Hello and welcome to Python Bytes,
where we deliver Python news and headlines
directly to your earbuds.
This is episode 305, recorded October 10, 2022,
and I am Brian Okken.
- I'm Michael Kennedy.
- We got a whole bunch of stuff that's great.
We also want to thank Microsoft for Startups,
Founders Hub, for sponsoring this episode.
We'll hear more about them later.
But do you want to start us off with something exciting?
- Let's kick it off.
I have a theme this week, Brian.
- Okay.
- Before we get to it,
If my voice sounds a little bit scratchy,
I just want to apologize.
It's not that I'm sick.
It's that I was rocking out to the Scorpions last night.
They were here in Portland,
and even if they're 70, they still rock.
It was amazing.
I don't know how old they are,
but they probably are up there.
- I don't know, maybe being sick
may have been a better excuse.
- Yeah, maybe. (laughs)
All right, I do have a theme, though, for the week,
and let's kick it off with that theme.
This first one, both of these are recommendations.
The first one came to us from Matt Kramer.
Thank you for that.
And Jeff Glass, I remember last time I said,
they announced PyScript, that is Python compiled
to WebAssembly running on top of PyIodide
and Wasm in the browser, which is amazing.
So many cool things and so much potential there.
I pointed out that that was released
and there were some breaking changes
and it was like last minute that I got that.
So I just threw it in as an extra,
but now I had a chance to look at it.
So there's a bunch of changes and I just wanna highlight
some of the things for people.
So they're using semantic versioning
and I don't fully understand this.
I guess it's just like month based, right?
So it's 2022.09.1.
That doesn't mean September 1st though,
it was released on September 30th.
So about 11 days ago, 10 days ago.
And they just reiterate this project
is undergoing lots of changes.
It's in its super early stages.
The calendar versioning doesn't really indicate
that it's like 0.1 or whatever type of level,
but there's a lot of breaking changes.
So if you've worked with it before,
just you wanna read through this
and figure out where things are going.
It doesn't look like anything's majorly broken
in like you've got to rewrite a ton of stuff,
but it also, there are parts that will stop working,
but they seem pretty easy to fix.
So first of all, like many Python programs,
you need to express your dependencies.
You would do that through a pyproject.toml
or requirements.txt,
unless you're on the web running the browser,
then nope, you don't do that.
Instead, what you would do
is you'd use this py-env section to express,
I depend on these packages,
either just a URL to a wheel, a Python wheel,
or something that could be pip installed using micro pip.
That's gone.
It's now deprecated and will be taken away.
So now that's folded into the py-config section,
and there's a way to just say
packages are a list of packages
and files that we're using is a list of paths.
And it's in these kinds of places where you indicate
what Python files you might write and import,
because while you can write Python in HTML,
just like JavaScript, you should do that very sparingly
and you shouldn't just write your, you know,
a thousand lines of Python like inline.
That's not a great idea.
So you would link over to a set of Python files
that you can run one of them and import others from that.
All right, so pyenv going away, folded into pyconfig.
This is one of the things that's easy to fix,
but like I said, will stop working.
They've also changed the syntax of some events.
So you might've seen people on HTML elements
like a paragraph or a div or a button,
say mouse over equals in some JavaScript function name,
like a function call, either inline function
or a function you've written.
In PyScript, there's a py-event.
So there's a pie dash mouse over
and a pie dash click type of thing.
And in here you can just write arbitrary Python.
And unlike JavaScript, you can actually
write arbitrary Python, separate multi-line Python
separated by semicolons, look at that.
Semicolons, they made it to Python.
You can write arbitrary Python,
it doesn't have to be a single function call.
Pretty cool, right?
- It is pretty cool.
Where Python's starting to turn into JavaScript
that is changing all the time.
- Exactly, well that's why the breaking changes.
No, just kidding, that's the new project,
but don't let it become JavaScript.
(laughing)
I'm very excited that maybe it could
supplant JavaScript to some degree.
There's some stuff about HTML escaping,
so you could do like print a string
and that will show up in the browser sometimes,
or you can get it to go to the console.
But if you put like one is less than two,
and that shows up in the browser,
you know, that might get interpreted as an opening bracket
instead of just a less than symbol.
So there's some fixes there, some stuff for logging.
The ability to run multiple runtimes.
So when people usually do PyScript,
they point at just a CDN version of PyScript,
which points at a CDN version of Pyodide.
But you can and easily can do,
you can download that,
customize it, and put it in
your static files and run it out of there.
You could possibly not even use Pyodide itself,
you could use, say, like, MicroPython, potentially.
Or you could actually have maybe different versions
of PyEdite running in different sections of your site,
if you wanted, so different PyScript blocks,
presumably even on the same page.
So, a lot of flexibility about managing multiple runtimes.
Let's see, a few other things.
There's also some major releases of PyEdite
that's coming along, and because it's built on top of PyEdite
or runs on top of PyEdite, PyScript does,
obviously the changes there are super important.
So some of the changes are that they broke,
it used to be kind of like one huge namespace
and they broke that up into a bunch of pieces.
So you got to know about that.
But probably the most relevant for people is
you used to have to do this thing
where you would import from JavaScript some event
and do like a proxy type thing to like hook an event,
which wasn't terrible, but it was kind of like,
well, he's still doing Python, I don't know.
Right, so they've written a bunch of event handlers
or event sources in pyodide ffi.wrappers.
So like add event listener, remove event listener,
set timeout, set interval, clear interval.
And so now you can just import, say like add event listener,
have a function, Python function,
and then you just say add event listener on a tag,
on an event, and here's your Python function.
That's awesome, right?
- That is awesome, yeah.
- Yeah, so they've added these event handler sources
that are straight Python and not interoperating
with JavaScript more directly.
There's a bunch of things behind the scenes
that will make it better,
like that we don't necessarily as users care about,
but like, and Scriptin is getting better.
They've got a whole testing scheme.
You might be interested in this, Brian, for your show.
They do integration tests with PyWrite.
They do TypeScript tests,
'cause a lot of the interaction bits are in TypeScript,
and they do that with Jest.
And then Python, the Python code gets tested with pytest.
That's an interesting mix, huh?
- I guess just pointing out, we said PyRite, it's PlayRite.
- Yeah, I'm sorry, I'm too much on the Py right now.
Yes, PlayRite, thank you for keeping me honest.
- Yeah, but I'll do a famous pull request on them
to try to get that pytest case all lowercase.
That'd be good.
- Yeah, I'm not even gonna use this project
until that gets fixed.
So some stuff on infrastructure,
there's new CI things that they're working on
to make it better.
They're using type annotations and they're trying to
synchronize TypeScript and PyScripts type annotations
to kind of keep the end to end across JavaScript,
across Python, accurate and a bunch of stuff that's coming.
In particular, a lot of the rethinking how async works
because JavaScript is already like super asynchronous
but it just has one loop and if you hook your async Python
into that and like, is it really async?
Yeah, it's a little bit complicated.
You can check out what they said there.
But otherwise, very exciting stuff.
And if you're doing PyScript, definitely check this out
'cause it's going to affect you.
- Yeah, that's cool.
Well, let's give your voice a little bit of a break.
- Yeah, I mean, too much Rocky Like a Hurricane
stuff going on.
- Yeah.
Well, I wanna talk about decorators a little bit.
So I was actually on a, I sat in on a Boston,
the Python Boston Meetup group.
It's kind of neat, they're still doing online.
So it's not really Boston, it's anybody can jump in
and have fun there.
But we're talking about pytest and the,
and Ned Batchelder was there
and talking about coverage also.
And he was showing us some of the test code,
it was kind of, it was really fun.
'Cause he was showing us some of the test code
within the coverage, the test code that tests coverage
by that coverage.py.
And he was showing some things that,
and then about using decorator shortcuts.
And then I was like, that's really cool.
I always forget to do that.
And so he wrote up this, I don't know if it's just for me,
but he wrote up a blog post called decorator shortcuts.
And especially, I mean, I guess for a lot of stuff,
we use decorators a lot in Python now.
And in pytest also uses a lot of decorators,
things like pytest mark parameterize
or pytest mark skip or X fail.
Those are all decorators built in part of pytest.
And so the thing he wanted to show us is like,
as an example, he's got some tests that have to,
that are either skipped or X failed
on certain Python versions.
So he's got a way to test that piece of code
that only works on, say, like, it doesn't work on PyPy,
or it doesn't work on like Python 3.8 or before
or something like that.
And so he has these fairly complex version,
like XFail decorator sequences that he can take.
And instead of saying, and let's say he's actually filed,
maybe there's an issue,
He's actually filed an issue against PyPy, for instance.
But his tests are still failing.
He had an example where instead of just
this whole big XFail blob with the environment,
checking the environment version,
and having a reason and a link to the defect,
he just shortcutted that to just like
a single variable name or single name
that says XFailPyPy3749, as an example,
just a single thing.
And then when you're using it,
instead of this whole big blob,
you can just write @xfail.
Instead of saying like pytestmark xfail,
you can have this specific xfail,
and then you get the reason printout and everything.
Now this is-- - That's very clever.
- Yeah, especially I like it for this,
is we were talking about how we don't like
to leave xfails in for a long time,
but sometimes you're dependent on a different piece
of software that you're not one of the maintainers,
in which case, what do you do with the failing test?
One of the things you can do is you can X fail it
and link it to a defect report so you can keep watch of it.
But yeah, having a way to just mark different tests
with the same thing, it's pretty cool.
And then this really kind of relates
to really a lot of things.
There's a lot of places where we use long,
long complex decorators that you can just assign to a variable and then use it later.
>> Yeah, to put this decorator on a test function,
you specify a whole bunch of conditionals around the version,
and then the reason is a big long string.
If that's affecting 10 tests,
you put that on 10 tests, it's all over the place.
One of the things that you hear from people sometimes like,
well, I don't like unit testing because it's hard to maintain.
I find that when people say that a lot,
they kind of go into this mode where,
when they're writing test code,
they forget about things like trying to isolate,
change to one place,
and you would never write the same code 10 times
in a real part of your app.
Why should you write it 10 times duplicate in a test?
Well, it's hard to maintain.
Well, it'd be hard to maintain
if you did that in your regular code too.
You don't do it there, so don't do it here.
This is a cool technique to accomplish that, yeah.
- Yeah, definitely.
>> This part of it, it's also great because it's consistent.
It'd be terrible if you were referencing this issue in three different places,
but only sometimes including the link and having some consistencies good.
There was some concerns,
Larry Hastings put up a concern about possibly not doing this for code
that generates a single use object,
like a iterator or something like that.
But just don't do that.
But Larry has a workaround.
You can do it a different way
if you have something that acts like that.
- I see, interesting, yeah.
There's a lot of turtles all the way down,
like decorators of functions that return functions.
And so what we do is wrap that in a function
to alleviate the capture, the closure.
- Yeah, it's fun. - Yeah.
But anyway.
So. - Cool.
Excellent stuff, yeah.
Next up, our sponsor. - Yeah.
We have a sponsor.
Our sponsor this week is Microsoft for Startups,
a founders hub.
So Microsoft for Startups founders hub provides all founders
at any stage with free resources
to help solve startup challenges.
The platform provides technology benefits,
access to expert guidance and skilled resources,
mentorship, networking connections,
and a whole bunch more.
And unlike others in the industry,
Microsoft for Startup Founders Hubs
does not require the startup to be investor backed
or third-party validated
or able to relocate to San Francisco for a short time.
So Founders Hub is truly open to all.
So what do you get?
You get free access to GitHub and Microsoft Cloud
with the ability to unlock credits over time.
They've also partnered with other companies like OpenAI
to provide services and discounts.
And Microsoft, through the Microsoft for Startup Founders Hub,
becoming a founder is no longer about who you know,
you'll have access to their mentorship network,
giving you access to a pool of hundreds of mentors
across a range of disciplines,
across areas like idea validation, fundraising,
management, coaching, sales, marketing,
maybe even testing, who knows?
You'll be able to book a one-on-one meeting
with the mentors,
many of whom are former founders themselves.
So make your ideas a reality today
with the critical support you'll get
from Microsoft for Startups Founders Hub.
And to join or just check it out,
visit pythonbytes.fm/foundershub2022.
The link is in the show notes.
And I know you can find this stuff on your own
with Google or something,
but if you go through our link,
it helps them know that you heard about them here.
So thanks.
- Yeah, thanks Microsoft for supporting the show.
Brian, before we move on,
audience feedback from Henry Schreiner.
For that exact example, talking about pytest and decorators,
I'm not fond of making the test directory importable
unless I have to.
A mark might be better.
What do you think?
- A mark might be better?
I mean, they are marks.
So the marks are decorators.
- Yeah, okay, cool.
What is next?
Another continuation of my theme here.
So Mark Madsen sent over a recommendation
to talk about this, unrelated to the previous announcement,
only in timing or origin.
So Panel, people probably have heard of HoloViz
and Panel is related to that project.
It's an open source Python library.
It lets you create custom interactive web apps
and dashboards by connecting widgets, plots, images.
So people have heard of Streamlit,
they've heard of H2O Wave, they've heard of Plotly Dash.
It's like in that category, right?
So you can put together a lot of interactive fun pieces.
So for example, here, if you go to the main website for panel,
you can see that there's this graph.
As you hover over it, it's very interactive,
but you also have widgets to let you
re-evaluate how you compare all these things and just play with it live.
Kind of like it's a notebook, but it's not. That's neat, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So traditionally, this has run in Jupyter Notebooks,
or you can run it on the Flask backend type of thing.
You can host it on your own server.
The news is not that.
This has been around for a while.
The news is that Hanel now comes to Wasm via Pyodide
and has PyScript integration.
That's pretty awesome.
- That is pretty cool.
- So in order to host it before,
you have to either have a running notebook server
or you had to set up your own separate web server
and maintain that thing and all that goes with.
And now you can just put a little py-config in there
and boom, when they interact with your data
and they run it, it just happens client side.
No servers needed.
So let's talk about some of the things here.
You can automatically convert panel applications
to a Pyodide version, a couple of flavors,
reasons I'll explain in a minute,
or you can convert to a PyScript based app,
which is pretty epic.
So like you could embed a panel
inside your Sphinx documentation,
just as HTML, which is pretty nuts.
So there's this convert command,
panel space convert on the CLI,
and you can tell it the two format
from your regular panel code to convert it to a Pyodide.
This one is good if you want to have a single HTML file
that you say, here's my HTML file, off it goes.
It's just no dependencies.
And then it runs there.
That's not as good as creating a Pyodide worker,
which creates a JavaScript and HTML file
that you got to serve over more of a server,
or you can even output a PyScripts version
where you can write additional PyScript code.
It's pretty epic.
And here you can see a little example.
This looks like standard XGBoost SKLearn code right here.
That does all its things.
Except for the end, you just say pn.column,
and here's your output right there.
And you put your little pipeline you created
and maybe a head of a data frame to show up,
and there it goes.
So in order to run this,
you would say panel convert the script
to a Pyodide worker, output Pyodide.
Then you just run a server locally
so that you can get to it and can pull in the JavaScript,
open it up and you get something that looks like this.
That's super interactive.
There you have machine learning in the browser.
That simple.
- That's pretty cool.
- The browsers, JavaScript will take over the world.
It'll like get smart and then take off.
So a couple of cool tips and tricks they recommend
is you can do --auto reload.
So if you make changes to the file,
it'll auto reload the browser.
So just as you edit,
you can also add a panel.convert --watch.
So if the source files change,
it'll regenerate the script
and then the script will get reloaded.
So like you can chain those together, I believe.
Then there's a section on formats that actually describes
what is the point of the different outputs
like PyDiver's PyDiverWorker.
So the worker one says it generates an HTML file
and JavaScript that runs better.
this is the most, in a separate thread,
this is the most performant option,
but it has to be running out of a server
instead of just a file.
Worth noting here, PyScript generates an HTML file
leveraging PyScript, produces standalone HTML files
containing pyenv and PyScript tags with the dependencies.
It's basically a PyScript variant of the Pyodide one.
Well, guess what?
This might need a little update, coming soon.
Py-DENV is not there anymore, so they can check that out.
I'm sure they're on top of it.
- Yeah.
- Final thing to note here that's pretty dope
is progressive web apps.
So this comes with a --PWA option,
which turns your,
I'm pretty sure this is gonna require
the PowerDyed worker variant,
'cause you need these worker things
for progressive web apps.
But this means that you can install
your app into say an iPad
or install it like a desktop app
and run it with cached offline data.
So for example, let's see if I go to YouTube here.
I signed in, no.
Good, so like in Vivaldi, I can right click on this
and it'll say, install YouTube there.
So if you did that option for your panel app,
you could right click and say, install panel.
And you might think, oh, well, that's silly.
Like who cares about that?
Let's see if this, this let me do it though here.
Oh, this is live.
If you go to a lot of these,
just need some video, I don't really care where it is.
Um, a lot of these you can come in and actually click download.
I guess you got to be signed in, but if, if you're like a premium account,
or you can click download and that's only possible for YouTube installed as a PWA.
Cause I think a lot of people feel like, Oh, it just gives me an icon on my
homepage, but like, there's actually different behaviors.
So you can get like offline videos on the PWA YouTube, whereas the web one,
you can't and so on.
So anyway, that's the kind of benefits you would get if you would do your
panels at PWA, which is just a command line option.
Interesting.
Cool.
Anyway, people check it out if they're interested
in building dashboards, they're interested in PyScript
and running in the browser using WebAssembly,
here's a pretty awesome option.
Thanks, Mark, for sending this in.
- Yeah, thanks a lot.
Did you know that Python 3.11 is coming right up?
- It's gotta be soon, it's October.
There's not that much October left.
- Yeah, but it was 3.8 when we got the Walrus operator.
Do you realize it's been that long?
- It seems like the Walrus operator's still new,
but that's a long time, yeah.
- Yeah, so--
- So an adolescent walrus now, not even a baby walrus.
- Yeah, exactly.
So I think it's time for people to embrace the walrus.
And so one of the things you can do
is you can install Marco Garelli's AutoWalrus
and it'll convert your code for you
in places where you really should use the walrus operator.
So, and this is good if you're supporting 3.8 and above
And golly, I hope you're already up to 3.9 or 3.10 by now.
So there's this auto walrus, I checked it out.
It's pretty simple.
It can run as a pre-commit hook too, which is nice.
But you can run it on the command line,
which that's what I did when I tried it.
You pip install auto-walrus.
So it's one word, but with a dash in the middle.
And then you have this application,
you can run it on a file.
And like we've said, you can run it
as a pre-commit hook as well,
and it'll run on everything, but you can,
and it just converts stuff.
So if you have things like,
here's a simple example of n equals 10,
and then if n is greater than three, do something.
And that converts, the auto-while-res will convert that
to the while-res operator of if, you know,
n colon equal 10 is greater than three.
>> Nice.
>> I like this being separate from other tools because some people
just honestly haven't came on board with this already.
Embrace the walrus sort of thing.
But it's a fun way to just try it out on your code and do a diff,
get diff and see what it changed and maybe you like it.
Maybe it's a thing to do as a group code review thing
to just talk to your team and find out if you want to change it this way or not.
Yeah.
And then this reminded me of something.
I'm like, we had something like this before, right?
And back in episode 82.
Wow, that was in 2018.
We talked about Anthony Sotile's PyUpgrade.
So, and that's, it's been a while.
So, that's like four years ago.
So, I went and took a look again.
And I would like people to try to check out PyUpgrade too.
Because there's a whole it's moved on. So it's not just we recommended PyUpgrade for things like
upgrading to from two to three sort of thing. >> Was that back in the controversial legacy
Python days? >> Yeah. So there's and there's always times to go and revisit old scripts and
old applications that you're still maintaining and going, well, we don't really want to support
the old Python, but our code serves looks like the old Python. So let's take a look at some of
of this stuff. And it'll do things like, you know, the set
literal, some of the old some of the old things of and, and
doing comprehensions for you and better, the comprehensions
are cleaner looking. And then but there's also like different
print styles. But one of the things I wanted to point out is
if you go to the readme, you got to scroll all the way down or at
least halfway down, and you get things like the three six plus.
So there's these plus options. So you can say if you're running
and three, six or above run that.
But you also want to do like,
let's just go all the way down to like three, seven plus.
And there was a kind of a new way to run sub process
for instance, but you're, I mean,
and it just finds some of these things
and just changes it for you.
So it's kind of cool.
And some of the things you may not have remembered
the three in three, eight plus the LRU cache.
You used to have to do the LRU cache
call it as a function for your decorator,
but now you don't have to do the params.
Just some cleanup like that. It's just nice.
I try to run this every once in a while.
I guess public service announcement for this cool little project.
>> That is a cool project and going through
this huge long read me and looking at it as it gets later and later,
Python versions, it's like,
here are just a bunch of examples of how
Python has changed over the last few years.
Yeah, who need it has a like 604 type rewrites.
It'll rewrite Union, the Union operator to the bar operator.
That's in 310 plus.
That's nice.
Yeah.
Well, we got 311 plus coming soon.
Yeah, that'll be fun.
So awesome.
Well, that's our items, right?
Got any extras?
You know, I was going to have an extra but I'm going to save that for later.
So no, I don't do you have any extras?
- No extras, but I have a joke.
I do a quick follow up to this though.
This is a hint of what's coming next week.
I'm gonna talk, I think it's next week
I'm gonna cover this.
Refurb, have you seen Refurb?
- I don't think so.
- Refurb is a similar one that like,
we'll go through and give you recommendations
of here's the most modern way to do your thing.
So like, if you said, you know,
if value is in bracket XYZ,
it's like, you know, it's a little less efficient
than like why make a mutable list
when you could make it a tuple.
It's a little more efficient just to create the tuples too.
- Nice.
- If value is in parenthesis,
it'll suggest you change the parenthesis
or suggest using some pathlib operations
instead of with open operations.
Like instead of a context manager with open,
do a bunch of stuff,
you can just do path of thing dot retext.
You don't need to do the context manager,
just bam, there it is.
A bunch of cool stuff like that.
So anyway, one more.
And then also Flint.
I've talked about Flint a lot.
I love Flint.
Super straightforward.
It brings one of the most beloved things you can do
for upgrading your Python is convert all your variations
of string formatting to f-strings
just across a whole directory of Python files.
- Cool.
- A lot of different things to be running together,
but are you ready for our joke?
- I am.
- You had the comment about bring back the walrus,
or I feel like that could be a cool T-shirt, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So I came across this place a little while ago.
I don't know if you have any particular one
recommend here, but this place that has like funny, geeky t-shirts.
So I thought I'd just pull a couple of these up and see what you think about them.
So some of them are good.
I like the first one, the Mordor.
The Mordor fun run.
One does not simply walk into middle earth.
You have a, some for our data science friends out there.
It has a graph of two things that are very similar.
One is a shark attacks.
The other is ice cream cone sales,
and it says correlation does not imply causation.
Apparently ice cream sales and shark attacks
are closely correlated 'cause it's warm,
you go in the water.
It probably doesn't cause shark attacks.
- It might.
If you are more into math,
you have the distance raptor divided by time raptor
is the velocity raptor.
But there's some really good programming ones
in here as well.
Like this one, for example, check this out.
Go outside, the graphics are amazing.
And the picture of the shirt is like
a super low bit rate, like graphics.
(laughing)
Here's a good one.
Some lab person pouring like beakers
of clearly poisonous green stuff.
It says, forget lab safety, I want superpowers.
Oh boy, what about the, what do you think of this one,
Brian, here, the forecast for Alderaan?
So remember Alderaan is the home of Princess Leia that was blown up by the Death Star in
Star Wars.
And it says five day forecast Alderaan, Monday 72 and cloudy, Tuesday 74, Wednesday 15,000
degrees, no Thursday or Friday.
It's kind of mean, but it's also kind of awesome.
Yeah.
This is me.
Let me see if I can find one more.
One more programming one.
Oh yeah.
Let's see. Here's some good ones.
One, it has a floppy disk.
It says, "Kids today have no idea what this is."
Then this one here, Brian, this is the last one.
It's somebody holding a CD going into a drive and it just says,
"Never forget the CDs."
>> Yeah. CD drive.
I still love that old joke of a person calls into
IT help desk and says,
I need I need some help because my cup holders broken.
Yeah, just went in and spilled his drink all over me.
Come on man, you guys gotta get this.
They fix.
Yeah, so you could spend a lot of time on this page.
I'm not necessarily suggesting you get a shirt here or anything,
but it's pretty.
It's pretty awesome.
What makes me miss think geek?
I think it should have never.
Yes, hold it.
But we have we have other people coming up with good humorous
shirts.
So that's good.
Yeah.
Houston, we have dibs.
Putting the flag on the moon.
[LAUGHTER]
Dibs on the moon.
Got it.
So a more serious--
a couple quick follow up here.
Marco Garelli, from the project that you talked about,
the auto walrus, says, yeah, I love Pi upgrade.
And Will McGugan-- hey, guys--
we could use the Pi upgrade because Rich is
dropping support for 3.6.
So just clean it up.
>> Yeah. Then I want to follow up with
the first thing I was talking about, about the decorators.
Henry Schreiner said, I think I got the wrong one.
But for that example,
I'm not fond of making the test directory
importable unless I have to,
a mark might be better.
I guess I brushed that off too quickly.
I think I still not sure how I would use this.
If I were to put a bunch of these,
like if I had a project wide decorators that I wanted to use.
I don't know what the best way to do that would be.
It might be a non-test file that I would import.
I'll have to play with it. Thanks for Henry for bringing that up.
I'm not quite sure how to deal with that problem.
>> Indeed.
>> All right. Well, should we call it a week?
>> Let's call it.
>> All right. Thanks everybody for showing up.
We'll talk to you next week.